initially I wanted to write a role for
myself that was you know what being
great big role and I wasn't very happy
with the type of work I was getting and
so I thought I'd take the law into my
own hands
it seemed like the kind of role that I
could possibly play well I'd done a lot
of wild in the theater and in the cinema
and and in one sense also he's a kind of
patron saint to me so some of the many
reasons really being a writer is is a
completely different world
it's a welding you're really on your own
you're motivated by yourself and writing
in a way in the process of the whole
process of making this film it it was
one of the easiest parts it was a long
time ago and it was it took quite a
short time and the challenges of being a
director and an actor are um I suppose
you know enormous and you just kind of
get through it really and for the best
all the other actors were wonderful
actors and like Rolls Royces and so for
that I was very lucky in one sense
because I didn't really need to do
anything to help them and my feeling is
that most actors like to be left alone
anyway to get on with what they're doing
in in in films and they were very
supportive to me in one sense because
obviously I had lots of other things to
think about apart from just acting and I
certainly could not have made the film
if it hadn't been with all these really
extraordinary actors because if someone
had had a really hard time in the acting
I don't know what how I would have
managed to add that to the kind of the
all the stuff I had to to do but the
thing was that even in the small parts
I had incredibly all the actors were
very overqualified and and amazing so
that wasn't really an area I had to
worried about too much my biggest
inspiration well a lot of people this I
wouldn't say one particular person has
inspired me and I thought that is the
way I want to go there's a collage of
people who have intrigued me and
fascinated me from and-and-and periods
you know I'm very fascinated by the
period for example that I became an
adult in the 1970s and lots of
characters from that here obviously in
cinema a lot of Italian directors I
liked very much
antonioni Visconti Sergio Leone and
Franco Zeffirelli those those directors
and they're kind of heavily textured
aesthetic really inspired me but equally
so did all the night the Hollywood films
from the 1950s or the James Dean
Montgomery Clift Marlon Brando films and
then also Hollywood from the 1930s I
adored all the different discoveries I
made of different genres through my
career I found inspiring and and but I
don't think one person in particular you
know advice is the one thing that I
think is a very bad idea in general I
think taking advice as a young actor is
is not necessarily a good idea and
giving it I think it's a very bad idea I
don't know how I would advise anyone
really I think you have to travel by
your own light in this business and
probably in everything in life and
advice to myself I would have just said
be a bit more serious about things
probably it's quite a cutthroat business
it can be quite it can seem quite cruel
because there's a lot of rejection
involved in it and the highs normally or
quite often are just the forerunner of a
low
and I think you need to have a lot of
stamina and you need to be able to keep
getting up when you've been knocked down
and I think that for someone like me
who's essentially quite wimpy has been
very very good because it's a struggle I
think a career is an act I think anyone
who goes into it thinking it's going to
be green lights all the way sometimes it
is by the way but mostly it's not and
mostly it's um it's it's it's it's a
tough journey some of it you know with
highs and lows and you have to know how
to to weather all those storms
[Music]
[Music]
[Music]